eu vim falar com vocês aqui sobre design
fim que é uma abordagem que mudou minha
vida eu queria compartilhar um pouco com
vocês um pouco da abordagem do design
thinking e como o que estou fazendo
enfim um pouquinho com essa abordagem
que está transformando a vida de algumas
pessoas três novos projetos enfim só
vocês conheceram um pouquinho antes de
entrar no design thinking
eu sou formado em administração e acabei
trabalhando por muitos anos na indústria
em dos siderúrgica metalúrgica
desenvolvendo projetos como como esse
fazendo design e design de produtos
enfim o produto final
por exemplo a máquina a batedeira
liquidificador a para abrir enfim ea
participar da produção de subir partes
desses produtos finais e na verdade
comecei a entender que a lógica de
desenvolvimento desse produto não estava
só na credibilização final e senti um
pensamento por trás que há toda uma
lógica por trás de desenvolvimento que
me fascinava até por exemplo nem na
indústria da id de desenvolvimento de
indústrias a da usina hidrelétrica por
exemplo que um sub partes de perfis que
eu desenvolvia que é pra pra usina isso
me fascinava comecei a entender que o
design não tava só na estética na forma
na função desses produtos finais mas sim
um pensamento que estava por trás e aí
eu comecei a mergulhar um pouco mais
nesse mundo do design comecei a entender
um pouco mais o que estava por trás do
design
e aí o que eu chegava para as pessoas
perguntavam quem quer dizer pra você e
as pessoas não entendiam se eu
perguntasse para vocês o que é design
que sem dizer por exemplo esse carro
olha o design desse carro ou por exemplo
esse prédio
a gente fala nossa que belo design ou
por exemplo mostra as imagens geralmente
não falam que aqui nós que coça a cabeça
não é isso aqui é um espremedor de suco
mas na verdade o design está muito além
da forma função estética
o design tem tudo a ver com o
significado que vocês dão para os
produtos finais
então na verdade eu aprendi que existem
dois tipos de design design natural e
design artificial
o design natural somos nós seres humanos
ea natureza são os animais são as
montanhas ea água são os rios
mas existe um design artificial
que a cadeira que estão sentados que é o
teto que está nos cobrindo enfim todo
tudo o que está no nosso entorno
desenhado por nós para nós certo
então na verdade comecei a entender que
o design é muito além só de produto só
aquele gráfico só aquela imagem vocês
encaram como design design tem a ver com
projetar projetar soluções para as
pessoas
se a gente está falando de design está
falando design para as pessoas e eu
falei 'bom eu voto no design artificial
que é natural não é minha competência
então como eu posso até entrar nesse
mundo e aí eu me deparei em 2009 foi o
grande ponto de virada na minha carreira
que eu me deparei com design fim com o
professor embora ele chegou para mim e
falou ele me explicou todo o conceito
tive um curso em burnley e ele me
explicou todo o conceito de design king
por trás de toda tangibilização de
alguma coisa existe um pensamento existe
um processo então já enfim que ele veio
com um processo com uma metodologia para
auxiliar no design de coisas que têm um
significado para as pessoas e comecei a
pensar e refletir será possível que a
gente não pode fazer o design de coisas
do nosso entorno melhores para nossas
vidas
será possível que não pode construir
estradas ruas da cidade são projetados
para as pessoas outros carros e eu me
coloquei a pensar eu quero isso quero me
aprofundar mais isso entendeu eu passei
um tempo estudando isso lá fora
passei 2009/2010 estudando me
aperfeiçoando no sistema e eu acabei
entrei comecei a perceber que o processo
de aprendizagem para construir soluções
construindo ações tinham a ver com erros
tinha a ver com e rááá constantemente
isso me fascinava quanto mais errado mas
eu aprendia e outra coisa eu comecei a
perceber através do design que as os
times as pessoas construindo soluções
hoje sozinhas não conseguem mais não
existe mais um herói
hoje existe os times colaborativo um
olhar multidisciplinar
sabe aquela história aqui o várias
cabeças pensando pensam melhor do que
uma sozinha então eu comecei a aprender
o valor dessa colaboração e além disso
se eu estou projetando coisas para as
pessoas a se relacionar com elas
precisam olhar para ela se sentiu o
problema delas e comecei a entender a
empatia e aí comecei a perceber que
tinha um conceito muito maiores atrás do
design thinking
a gente chama hoje são quais são os
valores que permeiam a enfim o primeiro
desempate se eu estou projetando alguma
coisa para alguém é preciso sentir o
problema do outro é preciso vestir o
sapato do outro eu preciso me colocar no
lugar do outro para que aí sim eu posso
colaborar com ele para ele colaborar
comigo projetar soluções e eu me coloco
a pensar será que existem essas soluções
e produtos e serviços que têm no nosso
dia a dia na nossa sociedade
será que são projetados para nós o tudo
a mesma coisa tudo parecida
automaticamente quando eu me coloco no
lugar do outro
a colaboração emerge naturalmente a
colaboração o remédio porque é do ser
humano a gente quer colaborar com esse é
um outro valor muito forte do design
thinking
eu coloco no lugar do outro para
projetar uma solução pronta que faça
sentido para o outro eu colaboro com ele
colaboram comigo projetar soluções
porque hoje sozinha não sou mais o herói
não dava para desenvolver as soluções
sozinho e precisa de mentes pensando ea
outra coisa que a experimentação e
preciso experimentar caminhos é preciso
errar aprender constantemente para
projetar soluções que vá sentir na vida
das pessoas
e aí eu comecei entrar um pouco mais a
fundo nas teorias enfim entender um
pouco mais quais são os pilares que
sustentam o safin ea gente chegou à
conclusão que existem três pilares de um
processo que vou passar pra vocês têm as
equipes multidisciplinares que a gente
chama de perfil t e tem os espaços
adaptáveis e aí o primeiro deles que eu
coloco aqui são os perfis de antigamente
na tecnologia se falar com excepção do
perfil e do especialista qual vai ser a
sua carreira você especialista em alguma
coisa e você doutora especialista em
alguma coisa
só que na verdade existem milhares e
milhares de problemas de uma sociedade
que não será excepção doutor para
solucionar
você pode selecionar criativamente
problemas usando várias cabeças de
diferentes formações e aí eu pergunto
pra vocês ao longo do processo de
formação na faculdade por exemplo você
tem interação pessoal de engenharia
administração direito enfim
dificilmente a gente tem interação com
esses com esses outros grupos
e aí o conhecimento gerado a partir da
especialização e hoje os problemas são
tão complexos que eu acredito que a
gente pode solucionar de forma mais
colaborativa então surge no dia em que o
perfil ter que é uma linguagem que
conecta
todas as disciplinas uma linguagem que
permite que nós possamos dialogar e
conversar no mesmo nível para produzir
soluções
além disso tem os espaços adaptáveis
porque os espaços adaptáveis tem uma
brincadeira do inglês que fala é do
inglês instalações e facilidades em que
é to facilitate que é tem que nos
facilitará as instalações 32 facilitar
será que os modelos as salas de
trabalhos espaço que a gente constrói
soluções são os melhores lugares para a
gente nos facilita no dia a dia
na verdade o espaço eles têm que ser
adaptadas aos nossos comportamentos e
não o contrário
então às vezes não coloca em situações
um falando para vários será que é o
melhor modelo será um modelo melhor
modelo de aprendizagem então na verdade
o espaço tem que moldará ajudar a gente
não encontraram travar os nossos
processos é que as salas de aula são
projetados para facilitar os processos
enfim hoje a gente começa a pensar em
modelos diferentes modelos mais
adaptáveis e além disso vêem o processo
como eu tenho você sente falou do seu
perfil ter a gente falou a os espaços
adaptáveis e agora vou falar do processo
o desenho animado que é um dos designers
superfamosos na inglaterra e falou o
seguinte vou desenhar o processo de
design como acontece o processo de
design
ele fez esse rabisco aqui onde ele
mostra começa assim ea gente termina
assim que estava querendo dizer que que
a gente navega há uma complexidade muito
grande e aqui a gente precisa começar a
chegar a algumas conclusões alguns
conceitos para poder definir o design de
alguma coisa e assim que acontece na
vida então tem um estudo feito pelo
design com sede na grã bretanha
falando como que são alguns dos
processos de sucesso os produtos de
sucesso como que emergem os produtos de
sucesso
então surgiu um processo a partir de um
estudo que fizeram com os grandes
produtos de nick portenho snic apple e
em todos os produtos usados por entender
o que está por trás que a gente tem essa
necessidade de quebrar em fragmentos
para entender a complexidade do todo
só que eles perceberam que o processo de
construção desses produtos não tinha um
processo detalhado passo-a-passo abc e
tinha um processo de expansão que a
gente chama de descoberta e definição do
problema
depois um processo de desenvolvimento
entrega de solução e assim eles
começaram a perceber que todo o processo
de pensamento que estava por trás dessas
soluções tinham só esse pensamento de
divergência e convergência
e aí o que que é a divergência vocês têm
um ponto de vista sobre alguma coisa eu
colocasse um desafio aqui pra nós e
falar assim como a gente resolve o
problema da política no brasil ou mudar
sua pergunta qual é o problema da
política no brasil todo mundo falar em
corrupção
na verdade esse é o seu ponto de vista
talvez tenhamos outros pontos de vistas
aqui na sala e aí veio o momento da
riqueza da divergência
cada um de nós tem uma história cada um
de nós tem uma percepção cada um de nós
tem uma especialização e nessa
divergência criar opções são opções de
conhecimento que a gente está falando
possibilidades de conhecimento e aí vem
o momento de fazer escolhas que é
convergir
então esse processo de divergência e
convergência experiente a gente entender
como projetar soluções de forma mais
rápida
como a gente pode projetar suas tem mais
significado para as pessoas
enfim eu coloquei esse slide pra mostrar
pra vocês como é a vida como a gente
imagina a vida né
uma reta mas na verdade como ela
acontece e essa é a realidade a gente
tem altos e baixos a gente tem as
dificuldades existem os momentos de de
construção e desconstrução
na verdade a gente precisa aprender
muito com esse altos e baixos
então eu trouxe aqui um case só para
contar pra vocês como que a gente aplica
isso em 2011 eu tive a oportunidade de
criar uma empresa que chama design cruz
e a idéia era aplicar esse projeto de
inovação para as empresas junto com a
tecnisa que a empresa construtora em são
paulo
eles chegaram com o insight com uma
oportunidade de projeto pedindo para
desenvolver inovação uma garagem
a gente pensou nossa nossa garagem quem
mora em prédio aqui a maioria das
pessoas não percebe mas o prédio lugar
esquecido em um lugar feio era escuro a
gente mal aproveitado o prédio e os
lobbies os apartamentos são maravilhosos
é linda é brilhante tiros mas nós
moradores de apartamentos a gente não
passa pelo lobby a gente passa pela
garagem
então como transformar uma garagem a
partir de um olhar mais humano
projetando soluções para pessoas que ela
tem
significado pra elas então já chegou
algumas primeiras soluções por exemplo
cada vez mais em são paulo os
apartamentos estão mais apertados
menores enfim a gente chegou a uma
solução por exemplo subsolo oficina nada
mais é que vocês todos vocês armas uma
furadeira utilizado durante 20 horas ao
longo de uma vida inteira então se vocês
têm furadeiras na casa de vocês vão usar
20 horas na vida inteira então na
verdade a gente pensou por que não tem
uma furadeira coletiva e colaborativa na
garagem onde todos pudessem usar e assim
pra todos os outros equipamentos
aqui a gente pensou a gente descobrindo
o projeto que todo prédio existe uma
existe um problema típico alguém quebra
a perna você recebe seu avô idoso alguma
pessoa que precisa de uma vaga um pouco
mais espaçosa desenvolvemos para uma
vaga que é de uso coletivo do prédio
temporária que você pode utilizar o que
a gente chama de vaga a mão na roda
então morador ele pode chegar lá ó eu
estou com meu filho ele quebrou perna
ele precisa uma vaga é para abrir a
porta em vidro pode utilizar então
chegamos à conclusão que temos que
projetar alguma solução que fizer
sentido para essas pessoas uma outra
delas subsolo alto organizado também
tinha o foco comercial e aí nós chegamos
a uma solução inspirada no cinema que
você escolha o seu lugar de 60 no cinema
aqui a gente falou bom vamos organizar a
garagem de um shopping center por
exemplo para que as pessoas possam
chegar mais rápido à chegam com pressa
não chega 15 desesperados para parar o
carro ea gente não sabe a decisão de
parar o carro
então na verdade você chega e aperta o
botão a gente direcione exatamente para
a vaga que você vai parar seu carro
muito mais fácil é muito mais eficiente
enfim você não fica aquele estresse e
hawthorne e assim solucionar o problema
de vaga de idosos
o vaivém de deficientes porque as
pessoas não respeitam a gente é
impressionante que as pessoas não
respeito enfim a gente fez uma série de
projetos uma série de iniciativas com
diversas grandes empresas do brasil ea
gente não estava satisfeito a gente
a gente falou a gente possa disseminar
ainda mais essa abordagem então df mogan
o cara que inspira muita gente
ele falou o seguinte as pessoas aprendem
melhor fazendo as coisas aprender melhor
em equipes e elas aprendem melhor
fazendo as coisas de verdade e isso é
realidade da vida ela não aprende só nas
escolas então a gente começou a pensar
como é que a gente pode desenvolver e
disseminar a abordagem do design em que
a partir de projetos reais
e aí surgiu a idéia da gente montar uma
escola porque eu queria mostrar pra
vocês que todo ponto de vista é somente
um ponto de vista se eu perguntasse pra
vocês estão vendo aqui província falar
uma caneta
vocês vão falar uma mulher dizendo falar
qualquer tipo de coisa mas aqui é um
dado que eu coloquei pra vocês que é um
peixe e olhando de frente que o peixe de
lado
então todos temos um ponto de vista
então o que a gente pode poderá os
indivíduos e dia de olhar de múltiplos
pontos de vistas e respeitar o olhar do
outro então em 2012 a gente montou
escolas enfim que é uma gente brinca que
é pensando na prática mas deu pra
pensando contando história enfim
pensando em como solucionar a questão
não a gente vai praticar a gente vai
fazer ao invés de eu ficar pensando e
possibilidades e fazendo planos não a
gente vai fazer depois a gente vai ver
se faz sentido
então a gente montou uma estrutura
baseada na metodologia de projecto
projeto desde lênin onde os desafios e
não por meio de projetos
então a partir de projeto os alunos
aprendem como solucionar questões ea
enfim a gente montou um modelo assim a
gente um que a gente poderia sonhar o
modelo de aprendizagem onde você tem os
professores onde você tem os alunos onde
você tem projetos reais das empresas
e você tem os problemas reais da
sociedade
a gente fala a gente quer trabalhar essa
intersecção então a gente montou a
escola um objetivo de as empresas podem
fazer um investimento na escola
colocando desafios
os alunos desenvolvem isso que se criam
se o ciclo virtuoso soluções soluções
voltadas para a sociedade soluções
voltadas para o negócio e soluções que
têm impacto na vida das pessoas com
significado que as pessoas aprendem como
projetar soluções de forma criativa
além de ficar sentado numa sala de aula
que muda completamente
então a gente montou um modelo de
aprendizagem baseada em projetos são
quatro projetos o projeto de um dia uma
semana três semanas e seis semanas
ao longo desses projetos aumentando a
dificuldade vai manter na complexidade e
assim os alunos vão aprendendo com os
outros também não só os professores
forma de solucionar aquele desafio
então a gente tem um lema do processo
que mostrei pra vocês do duplo diamante
aquela aberta de emergência então a
gente criou nosso próprio que passa pelo
entendimento pela observação do problema
pela construção do ponto de vista
coletiva do grupo depois pela id ação
para o storm prototipagem enfim todo o
processo que mostrar pra vocês
enfim hoje são quase 250 alunos 70
projetos desenvolvidos e enfim site para
empresas parceiras no modelo
o design que mudou completamente a minha
vida eu acho que pode mudar a vida de
todo mundo eu acho que depois de
construído duas empresas eu acho que faz
algum sentido de disseminar essa
abordagem tem uma missão de formar uma
nova geração de inovadores no brasil
enfim eu acho que esse é o que eu tinha
para compartilhar com você sente
obrigada